Today we're learning English with Disney's
newest animation Raya and The Last Dragon.
Don't worry if you haven't seen this movie yet.
The clips that we've chosen for today's lesson
contain no spoilers, so you can keep watching.
And if you do you are going to learn lots
of connected speech, which is the way that we
connect and link words together in English,
and you'll learn phrasal verbs that you can
use in daily conversations and much more!
But before we begin let's check out what Parvin
says about our lessons. He says that he recommends
our channel to anyone that wants to learn natural
English because this is what we do every week.
We make lessons to help you learn fast natural
English without getting lost, without missing
the jokes and without subtitles. So make sure you
hit that Subscribe Button and the Bell down below
to join our community and Parvin, and make
sure you don't miss any of our new lessons.
In our Fluent with Friends Course we teach
you important grammar tips just like this one,
so that you can avoid making mistakes.
Of course in addition to learning
thousands of words we use in our everyday
speech, understanding fast speaking natives,
using correct pronunciation and
laughing along with all the jokes.
The best part is you can try it right
now for FREE with our 3 Mini Lessons.
Just click up here or down in the description
box below to learn more and sign up now.
Before we continue learning
with this incredible movie,
and if you want to learn more about how
we connect and link our words togethe,r
to help you understand fast native speech
and also to speak more naturally and fluently
I highly recommend you check out this
lesson we made over on our other channel.
You can click up here or down in the
description box below to watch that next.